안녕하세요. 시도영입니다. 한 7,
8년 전쯤 인터넷에서 나이키의 빈티지
코르테지를 봤었던 기억이 있어요.
저는 나이키의 코르테즈라는 신발에
깔끔하면서도 기본기에 충실한 디자인을
참 좋아하지만 개인적으로 현재의
코르테즈는 너무 통통하게 나와서 발이
작아 보이고 통이 큰 바지와도 잘 안
어울린다고 생각해서 손이 잘 안
가더라고요. 그런데 라스트가 길고
날씬하게 빠진이 빈티지 코르테지를
보고 비슷한 모양세를 찾다 보니까
납작하고 길게 빠진 신발들을 좋아하게
됐습니다. 이번에 신발장을 보니까
제가 납작한 신발들이 유독 좀
많더라고요. 이전에 소개해 드렸던
프라다나 포라든 슈메이커스의 로폰을
제외한 제 납작한 신발들을 오늘 좀
소개해 드리려 합니다. 처음 소개해
드릴 제품은 아디다스의 도쿄
모델입니다. 오늘 소개해 드리는 제품
중에 가장 손이 잘 가는 제품인데요.
옛날에 나온 납작한 모델의 아디다스
신발들을 찾던 중이 신발에 꽂혀서
구매하게 됐습니다.이 온라인에서 보고
어 내가 찾던 스타일이다 싶어서 신호
보고는 바로 작년말에 구매하게
됐어요. 여러 조합과 재질로 나오는데
저는 가장 신기에 무난한 흰색과
초록색의 조합으로 선택을 하게
됐습니다.이 이 신발은 사실
에어포스나 뭐 스탠스미스, 코르테즈
등 우리가 흔히 신는 일상적인
모델들처럼 어디든 잘 어울립니다.
저는 봄여름에 가장 많이 있는 흰티와
청바지에 일단 붙여 보긴 했는데요.
깔끔하고 무난해서 어느 코디에든 녹일
수 있는 모델입니다. 다만 조금의
단점이 있다면 일단이 모델은 어퍼가
폴리에스텔로 되어 있어서 오염에 꽤나
취약합니다. 보시다시피 제도 꽤나
오염이 많이 되어 있어요. 만약
이런게 싫으신 분이라면 다른 가죽
어퍼를 가진 도쿄 모델을 선택하시는
걸 추천드립니다. 저는 발볼이 넓은
편은 아닌데이 제품 자체가 날씬나게
빠져서 한 사이즈 업을해서 신고
있습니다.이어서 또 다른 아디다스
제품을 소개해 드리려고 하는데요. 두
번째는 웨이스 보너와 아디다스의 협업
시리즈 중 2022년에 출시한 쌈바
제품입니다. 저는 웨이스보너 시리즈를
워낙 좋아했어서 몇혈레에 갖고
있어요.이 웨이스 보너와 아디다스
협업 라인은 무난하면서도 어디서나 볼
수 있는 느낌이 아닌 디테일이
하나씩은 있는게 마음에 듭니다.이
제품의 어퍼는 스웨이드와 나일론으로
되어 있고 정직한 빨간색을 지니고
있습니다.이 빨간색을 활용한 아디다스
신발은 종종 보이긴 하지만이 제품은
소재 덕분인지 좀 더 고급스럽고 깊은
색감으로 표현되어 있습니다. 마음에
드는 작은 디테일들이라면 일단
신발끈이 웨이스 보너스로 온 크로쉐
디테일을 갖고 있어요.이 크로쉐
디테일은 웨이스 보너의 자체
컬렉션에서도 자주 볼 수가 있습니다.
그리고 신발 양옆 아디다스 3선은
악어 가죽 같은 느낌에 지니고 있어서
비단 가볍게 표현되지 않은 부분이
마음에 듭니다. 그렇다고 또 너무
무게감이 있지도 않고요. 저는 이런
쨍한 색감의 신발에 봄에 씻는 걸
즐기는데 중청의 청바지와 특히 잘
어울리기 때문입니다.이 이전에 같은
옷에 신는 독 모델이 전체적인
분위기에 잘 녹아들어 무난하다면이
빨간 쌈바은 중천과 배색을 잃어서
포인트로 제격이 되어 줍니다. 그래서
같은 힌티의 청바지에 신어 주더라도
신발 쪽에 치중되는 비중이 조금 더
강해져요. 흰 청바지가 너무
심심하다면 위에 간단히 입고 벗셔츠를
걸쳐 줘도 좋습니다. 신발색이 너무
강하다고 해서 어렵다고 생각하는
분들이 종종 계시는데 보시다시피
생각보다 그렇게 튀지는 않습니다.
이전에 나온 재팬 모델도 좋아하지만
저는 봄여름에는 이런 쨍한 색감을
하나씩 섞어 주는게 산뜻해 보여서
좋더라고요. 다음은 온러닝과
포스터카이브 팩션에서 나온 클라우드
벤처 피크 모델입니다. 개인적으로
온러닝과 포스트 아카이브 팩션의 협업
중 제일 좋아하는 색감이자
모델이에요.이 이 신발은 일반적인
다수의 온러닝 신발 같은 러닝용이
아닌 트레일용으로 만들어졌습니다.
그래서 바닥 접지력이 탁월하고 소리
러닝용에 비해서 조금 더 얇게
나왔어요. 어퍼는 파프 협대 답게
슈레이스가 비대칭으로 되어 있습니다.
일반적인 온러닝의 모델과 차이가
크지는 않아요. 다만 한 가지
개인적으로 마음에 드는 건이 일반적인
운러닝의 모델에는이 온의 로고가
굉장히 크게 적혀 있는데이 파프와의
협업에는 적혀 있지 않아서 보다
깔끔해 보인다는게 마음에 듭니다.
러닝용으로 나온 클라우드 몬스터도 잘
신고 있습니다. 그런데 그 모델은
소리 상대적으로 좀 벌키해서 운동을
하거나 반바지를 입는 계절에 좀 더
자주 신습니다. 개인적으로는이 벤처
모델이 그냥 신기에는 좀 더 무난해서
선호가 더 높긴 해요. 다른 납작한
신발이 그렇듯이이 신발도 발볼에
비해서 길이가 길게
빠졌습니다.이 모델을 신는 다른
분들을 보니까 테크웨어 등을 같이
붙여 입으시더라고요. 저는 그냥 좀
넉넉하고 편하게 입을 때이 모델을
자주 꺼내신습니다. 그래서 오버하게
나오는 윌리 차바리아의 상하이와 같이
붙여 봤어요.이 이 제품을 다양한
바지들과 제가 붙여 봤는데 확실히 뭐
청바지나 슬렉스보다는 나일론 등의
아웃도어 소재등과 잘 어울리더라고요.
개인적으로 폴리에스테르나 나일론
소재로 된 바지 등등과 입어서
분위기를 맞추지 않으면 그냥 나
온파프 신었다 광고하는 느낌이라서
이렇게 유명한 제품일수록 좀 더 신경
쓰려고 합니다.네
번째 신발은 르메르의 24s 시즌에
출시한 수리 로퍼입니다.이 이
수리로는 주로 여성 라인에서 자주
나오는데이 시즌에는 남성에도
나왔었어요. 올 시즌에는 찾아보니까
없는 것 같더라고요. 요정 신발처럼
생긴 수리 로퍼는 어퍼와 텅이 하나의
가죽으로 이루어져서 중앙부가 접혀
있는 것이 특징입니다. 풀그레인의
종류 중 하나인 나파 양가죽으로 되어
있어서 신었을 때 정말 독보적인
부드러움을 느낄 수가 있어요. 다만
한 가지의 단점이 살짝 있다면
중앙부가 납작하게 눌려 있어서 발에
넣으면 발가락 때문에 앞쪽이 볼록하게
튀어나옵니다. 완벽하게 납작한
깔끔함을 기대한다면이 부분이 아실 수
있는데 신다 보면 그 나름대로 또
괜찮습니다. 결국 우아하게 빠진 모양
탓에 클래식한 더비처럼 활용하는 건
생각보다 쉽지 않습니다.이 이 신발은
르메를스럽게 그러니까 클래식과 캐주얼
사이 균형잡힌 활용을 하는 것이 가장
잘 어울리는 것 같습니다. 가장
안전한 선택지는 제가 입은 것처럼
르메르끼리 있는 것이고요. 기호에
따라 뭐 크롭 바지나 반바지에 신어
주어도 예쁘고 아니면 제가 입은
것처럼 긴 와이드한 바지에 신어
주어도
괜찮습니다.이 수리 로퍼는 이번
시즌엔 아쉽게 여성 제품으로만
나왔습니다. 다음 시즌에 또 나올지
모르지만 이번 시즌에도 그래도 꽤
예쁜 남성용 로퍼가 있더라고요.
아나토믹 로퍼라는 제품인데 신호
보니까 얘도 가죽이 정말 부드럽고
예쁩니다. 국내에는 한남 르메르만
들어오는 것으로 아는데 한번 확인해
보셔도 좋을 것 같습니다. 마지막으로
소개해 드릴 제품은 반스볼트의 어센팅
라인 드레스 블루 컬러 제품입니다.이
신발은 오늘 소개해 드리는 신발 중에
가장 연식이 오래된 제품이에요. 제가
6년 전쯤에 미국 여행을 갔을 때
반스 매장에서 구매한 제품입니다.
볼트라인은 많은 분들이 아시다시피
반스의 프리미엄 라인으로 리브랜딩을
목적으로 2023년 말에 공식적으로
종류됐어요. 현재는 같은 지향점을
지내고 있는월바이 반스 OTW
라인으로 그 명맥을 이어가고
있습니다. 저는 솔직하게 배경 지식
없이이 신발의 색감이 단순히 예뻐서
구매한 사람이기 때문에 당시에는이
볼트라인이 얼마나 좋은지는 잘
몰랐습니다. 볼트라인과 일반 라인은
외형 쪽으로 드러나는 것보다 차이점이
더 많이 있더라고요. 볼트와 일반
라인은 생산 공장도 다르면서 캔버스나
가죽 등 소재에 있어서도 당연하게도
볼트가 더 품지 좋은 것을
사용합니다. 다만 소비자 입장에서
드러나는 차이는 가격과 중창
정도예요. 일반 라인은 6에서 8만
원 정도라면 볼트는 10에서 20만
원의 가격이 형성됩니다. 그런데
솔직히 볼트라고 큰 차이는 못
느끼겠습니다. 찾아보니까 지금 제가
가진 모델은 리셀가 30만 원대까지
올라갔는데이 정도로 구매할 건 아닌
것 같더라고요. 확인해 보니까 거의
똑같이 생긴 어센틱 제품이 지금
39,000원에 판매 중이더라고요.
지금 제 반스 볼트 모델에도 고질적인
엽터짐이 생겨서이 친구를 보내주면
저는 저 모델로 새로 사려고요. 저는
평수에
260에는데이 신발은 275레벨
갔습니다. 아일립 부분이 완전히
다쳐서 좀 깔끔하게 신는 걸 좋아하기
때문에 사이즈를 오버하게 갔어요.이
이 제품은 반스가 그렇듯 정말
이곳저곳에 잘 신고 있습니다. 제가
자주 입는 르메르의 트위스테드
데임에도 자주 입고 그냥 편의점 갈
때도 신고 스웨이드 재켓에도 붙여
봤습니다. 드레스 블루라는 은은한
파란색이라서 중청의 대임, 회색
트레이닝 팬츠 등 우리가 일상적으로
자주 있는 바지들과 조합이 굉장히
좋습니다. 위에서 말씀드린 대로
대체품의 가격이 워낙 좋기 때문에이
반스 일반 모델을 하나 사두고
휘뚜루마두르 신기에 좋을 것 같아서
추천드립니다. 예전에 댓글 중에 제가
가진 로퍼를 소개해 달라는 분이
계셨습니다. 사실 제가 가진 로퍼들로
가안을 짜봤는데 다 좀 비슷하게
생겨서 이걸로 뭔가 좋은 영상을
선보이기가 어렵더라고요. 께서 완전히
그분이 원하시는 내용은 아닐 수
있지만 로퍼를 포함해서 제가 현재
좋아하는 납작한 신발들을 좀 소개해
드려 봤습니다. 제가 개인적으로
생각했을 때 오늘 제품 중 디자인이나
가격 측면에서 접근성이 높은 제품들이
몇몇 있게 나중에 참고해 보셔도 좋을
것 같습니다. 오늘 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다. 감사합니다.